it's hard enough to get mental health
treatment in the US but it's even harder
if you're not white
studies show that racial and ethnic
minorities are significantly less likely
to receive mental health treatment than
whites so we reached out to experts to
find out why it's so hard for people of
color to get help the first thing is
stigma in other words shame or disgrace
that can make people feel excluded
stigma is a big deal in the u.s. but
especially in communities of color
the asian-american community has a high
amounts of depression and anxiety and
other mental illnesses just like every
other community even when people might
get connected to a health care provider
often the family doesn't understand they
feel like if it's known that their child
is seeking health that that the family
will be looked down upon your cultural
value or cultural seeker circle does not
afford you the possibility of asking for
help not being even able to even
verbalize that piece then leads people
to very dark corners and very dark
places depression in untreated
depression in those cases oftentimes
leads to suicidal ideation or drinking
or substance use of some sort the second
reason is a lack of cultural competence
cultural competence is a doctor's
ability to recognize the different
places their patients are coming from
and then be able to adapt to their needs
traditionally African Americans will not
come in and say I'm depressed they'll
say I'm sick and tired of being sick and
tired
fatigue is a real clear sign so they'll
not really even appreciate themselves
that what they're experiencing is a
mental disorder because that's
considered frailty and frailty is
something that's not really considered
acceptable in a community that consists
of most of mostly working people a
person might be considered psychotic if
they have if they say they believe in
ghosts
but this is a cultural belief sometimes
it can rise to the level of a delusion
but but sometimes it just has to be
taken into account not being sensitive
to culture can lead to a wrong diagnosis
and that's happened and it's led to a
legacy of distrust that distrust has
included outright racism during times of
slavery African Americans particularly
African American women were experimented
upon in terms of ob/gyn surgeries and
there's clear history of that they were
also subjected to an experiment called
the Tuskegee Experiment we're talking
about a federally funded 40 year
syphilis experiment that turned people
into human lab rats without their
knowledge and by the way that experiment
didn't end until 1972 and for people who
don't speak English finding a therapist
who speaks your language isn't easy on a
national scale the lack of of mental
health providers that speak other
languages is large think about the areas
of conflict right now the Middle East
there's a lot of people coming from
Syria who speaks Arabic fluently when
you think about people migrating from
Africa people from Ethiopia or every
tria that are coming to the United
States this I don't know how many
languages in India not everybody speaks
Indy finally there's a lack of providers
and few mental health care providers of
color which could go a long way into
tackling all the issues we just
discussed and while the Affordable Care
Act has helped a lot of people gain
access to treatment who's filling all
that demand and if people have to wait
for hours in line just to get treatment
which patients will fall through the
cracks
when it comes to mental health in the
u.s. there's a lot of talk and little
action